on sait combien la science est utile
dans la résolution des crimes depuis que
les experts se servent de l'ADN les
criminels savent que leur signature
génétique peut les trahir la science et
l'évolue à vitesse grand V et le
Laboratoire des sciences judiciaires et
de médecine légale du Québec en présenté
hier aux médias les dernières avancées
en analyse génétique pour en parler pour
se faire expliquer un peu ça je reçois à
Diane Seguin elle est directrice
générale de la biologie ADN du
Laboratoire des sciences judiciaires à
Montréal bonjour
bonjour madame Richie alors on parle de
généalogie génétique de phénotypage de
réseau d'ADN tout ça est assez
énigmatique en quoi ces technologies là
sont révolutionnaires et à quoi elles
vous servent
en fait on utilise ces technologies là
dans des cas particuliers n'ont pas sur
nos dossiers de routine on utilise les
analyses ADN
usuelles dans la majorité de nos coques
qui sont résolus avec les analyses
régulières dans certains cas de crime
très graves ou non résolus on est en
train de développer de mettre en place
au laboratoire certaines technologies
qui permettent d'avoir une information
sur
le portrait robot génétique donc les
traits d'une personne donc c'est pas une
identification d'une personne mais de
type d'individus donc ça peut donner des
orientations d'enquêtes on a également
accès à la généalogie génétique qui une
autre façon d'orienter les enquêteurs
donc ce sont des nouvelles technologies
qui permettent d'orienter les enquêtes
dans des dossiers qui ont où on a plus
aucune piste évidemment ça s'applique
pas à tous les dossiers il qu'on est
dans ces dossiers là en particulier de
l'ADN qui reste pour faire des analyses
supplémentaires et
vous parlez en fait vous parlez de
généalogie génétique et depuis un petit
moment on entend et on lit des choses
notamment qu'on arrive à faire des liens
avec l'ADN de membres d'une même famille
même éloignée qui permettent de remonter
jusqu'à un criminel c'est un outil qui
semble assez utile qui peut même
relancer des enquêtes
oui en effet la généalogie ainsi que
c'est une combinaison de deux services
si on veut la génétique pour faire des
liens entre certains individus qui
partagent une grande quantité d'ADN
commune et par la suite
la généalogie permet d'établir des
arbres généalogiques pour remonter vers
des ancêtres communs et puis redescendre
des branches généalogiques pour essayer
de cibler selon la géographie l'âge du
suspect par exemple
cibler un individu ou une famille qui
qui n'a pas mis lui son ADN dans ses
banques là mais donc ça nous permet de
chercher des individus mais par la suite
c'est très important on a ciblé un
individu les enquêtants vont faire leur
travail d'enquête vont nous apporter un
échantillon de comparaison et on va
pouvoir comparer l'ADN de cette personne
ciblée
siècle l'ADN retrouvé sur une scène de
crime pour confirmer l'identité de la
personne ça s'applique aussi au reste
humain non identifiés dont on fait
l'analyse au laboratoire donc dans un
cas où on a aucune idée de la personne
on peut utiliser ce genre de technologie
est-ce que vous avez confiance madame
Seguin que ce genre de technologie
pourrait permettre de résoudre des
crimes qui sont qui sont non résolues
forcément depuis des années
mais oui c'est un peu l'idée du brefage
technique on voulait informer les médias
qui ont travaillé sur certains dossiers
on a précisé qu'on ne parlerait pas de
aucun dossier en particulier donc c'est
vraiment pour informer les gens que le
laboratoire qui est sous le ministère de
la Sécurité publique qui travaille en
collaboration avec les policiers les
coronaires on travaille sur certains
dossiers pour tenter de résoudre des
dossiers qui sont non résolus donc c'est
le but c'est notre mission là en fait de
tenter de résoudre certains dossiers bon
on sait que fréquemment les policiers de
la province doivent faire affaire avec
des laboratoires américains privés
est-ce que en introduisant ces nouvelles
technologies on peut parler d'un point
tournant
mais en fait c'est pas fréquemment je
peux juste préciser que il y a eu
quelques cas où les policiers du Québec
ont fait à faire avec des laboratoires
américains on est en train de développer
la technologie ou laboratoire ça prend
du temps à acquérir les appareils
valider les méthodes s'assurer de la
qualité des résultats
donc on est en train de le mettre en
place les
partenaires policiers le savent qu'on
travaille sur ces technologies-là donc
si dans l'avenir moi j'ai beaucoup
d'espoir donc on va pouvoir résoudre
quelques dossiers bon c'est sûr que
c'est pas tous les dossiers là je veux
vraiment mettre l'accent sur ces des
dossiers particuliers de crime très
graves qui n'ont pas été résolues il y a
rien qui dit qu'on ne l'appliquera pas
éventuellement sur des dossiers
contemporains par exemple un dossier
d'agression sexuelle en série plusieurs
femmes se font agresser dans un dans un
intervalle très court on cherche un
individu on pourrait peut-être faire
affaire avec ces technologies pour
permettre d'avancer dans l'enquête bien
sûr il nous reste peu de temps mais je
vais vous entendre là-dessus c'est une
nouvelle technologie ça suppose bien sûr
des nouvelles contestations devant les
tribunaux quand on les utilisera il y
aura sûrement des batailles mais ces
outils là ils sont déjà testés ailleurs
oui on les utilise déjà aux États-Unis
même dans d'autres pays pour ce qui est
de l'aspect légal moi je me prononcerai
pas là-dessus nous on utilise les
technologies qui nous sont permises
d'utiliser donc avec des protocoles
particuliers c'est c'est tout le volet
légal là ça appartient plus le au
tribunaux de faire la suite là-dedans
absolument on sait que vous êtes
extrêmement utile enfin la science est
extrêmement utile au tribunaux merci
beaucoup et Diane Seguin
je vous remercie beaucoup au revoir pour
voir nos émissions en entier rendez-vous
sur la chaîne ici RDI